Samuel leaves here and we're here at our
partner meeting it's been absolutely
incredible every single partner this
right there in the mastermind session is
making lots and lots of money it's just
fantastic so I thought I'd introduce you
to some of the guys this is where we
have our board meetings and our
mastermind sessions at the hilton hall
absolutely fabulous views we've got this
is all our section up here at the top
and the boardroom meeting which we're
about to go into but gorgeous
surroundings so I'm sure you'll love it
see you later Andrew if he's camera shy
and we're just on a quick coffee break
now so I might even get to introduce you
to some people we've also got Tom Wade
here who's a millionaire he's in his 20s
[Music]
all right so here we are I have some of
the partners we've got Tom Waits say my
Tom we got Sandra Cindy you've got two
properties lined up you decide if we
came to buy for yourself we've got Jen
we've got Dennis and I found out
recently the dance is like a famous DJ
the boy does you were a famous DJs in
the house were trees and you slipped a
few deals you're buying some stuff
you've got loads of projects going on
we've got Chris good to see you Chris
Chris you use it to deal recently
haven't you he has we've got Steve
mckernon hey stay positive steel ball
these guys are celebrities between the
church how many girls have you slip
since she started nine how many of you
didn't pull knowing excellent so
eighteen between the two of them they're
crushing it and you're also buying
houses for yourself right yeah so that's
the idea you want to slip slip slip slip
by all we do here we've got John Lucy
ADA who's an absolute legend hi John
and how old's your son twenty years old
sir and it's just a lease option
agreement some stuff we've got Susan and
Julie who do are doing you've done some
big days together recently
excellent and I heard apparently you
slip five deals in smoke so
so Susan's than five deals and Julie's
kicking butt as well we love
Julie we've got iron coming those
reviews that you two started knowing and
when did you start
two months ago incredible Tyrone you've
made your money back you investment I
have yes and you use lip and dealers
left right and center in Middlesbrough
heavy arrow babe no is there the Bema
slipping deals left right and center and
Tom what are you going to talk about
today eventually Facebook Ads Facebook
Ads finals and how to get leads in way
of sleeping a funnel system you need
systems
incredible man high-five we can't wait
to go over there
so yes that's what we do here at the
country mansion Hilton Hall lit deals
make money invest buy properties and
ultimately make a difference in the
world we also have upstairs a team of
workers so builders project managers we
have solicitors accountant all kinds of
people that make sure that the business
is systemized and our partners can plug
into that as well so it's just
incredible so I hope you're having a
fantastic day doing whatever you're
doing and I think I'm going to enjoy the
rest of the day just chilling outside
the lake peace